on the bound for the padres just you
darvish making his 18th start second
career against the nationals last couple
times out going six innings
very good numbers
for you darvish the strikeouts 123 and
102 innings
stepping up the plate i'll see these
escobar escobar just joining the team
prior to this series in five games
hitting at 381
and he's played very well defensively
he's been a very good addition
right back to darvish and he makes the
catch
you says no i'm not sure
he caught that or it caught him but
either way
out number one for you darvish oh he
totally looks away
puts his club up in self-defense and
then watch his reaction
but it's in my glove really gold glove
material right there
next up trey turner turner got a
fastball up
darvish thinks it's gone so do we see
you
later trey's second first inning homer
of this series and the nats blast out on
top
four team fastball ran back over the
inner third he pulled those hands inside
it looks like he even hit this ball off
the end of the bat bob
well the all-star shortstop didn't hit
that one over 100 miles an hour 99
miles an hour but more importantly he
got a great launch angle let's see if he
gets that key
to start off this game there it is john
gomes the veteran catcher
the runners at second and third two down
a run in
gomes up the middle on a low fast ball
soto scoring ball bobbled by grisham
castro is coming home anyway and jan
gomes
checks in with a two-out hit
another knock with runners in scoring
position
the nationals already with a
three-nothing lead is max
scherzer 36-year-old three-time cyyoung
award winner seven-time all-star
unbelievable that he did not make the
all-star team this year that's another
story
tommy fan leading off for the padres
great slider in the foul tip with gomes
squeezing it strikeout number 128.
we pretty much showed tommy pham his
whole arsenal that ib
max is able to come out on top with the
slider
[Applause]
great job by john gomez ticking and
holding on to it two down last to the
first and it brings up jay crownerworth
high riding fastball not hit that far
and victor robles is going to go far to
grab it out in left center
thought it was going to fall but victor
robles makes the catch out there to rob
kronenworth
and the padres are down in order in the
first inning machado has had a good
series and tied for second of the league
and runs batted in with 59.
splits the outside edge with the heater
at 96 number two for max picture perfect
96
right on the black no chance for any
hitter to do much with that pitch
runners at the corners nobody out big
spot for josh bell
oh center field bell
up against the wall turner home juan
soto heading for third and the nats lead
four nothing
oh here comes the hot castro he doubled
first time
castro got a slider over the heart of
the plate lines out hard to center
soto coming home standing up it's five
nothing
so that gets bell to third with one on
the next lead five nothing
so here's josh harrison celebrating
birthday number 34.
see if he can pick up an rbi and
how about six nothing
[Applause]
on a no two count that was a fat
breaking ball
waiting to be hit up the middle and he
cannot wait to go out to left field to
tell the fans what he did this a-b myers
with a couple of solo homers
five for 19 career against scherzer
oh my look at that slider throw some
fastball set up the secondary pitches
strikeout number three seven straight to
start the game
jorge mateo will pitch it garbage done
after
three innings and 64 pitches allowing
six runs in his three innings of work
always can go to the fastball tonight
first time through the order they go one
for
nine and max has four strikeouts
top of the order tommy pham that's six
padres nothing one and two with two outs
got him looking my goodness what command
on the scherzer fastball tonight three
k's in the third
now one on here's trey turner he's two
for two
turner to center extension
c u later
two homers in a single
the gnats are on top eight to nothing
and for a second
i thought it was going to hit the top of
the wall and he was going to get a
triple
on his way to another cycle but we'll
take the long ball
we move to the bottom of the fourth
inning fernando tatis junior leading off
against max serzer
high drive deep left field fort fernando
upper deck 28th home run of the year for
tatis junior padres on the board in the
fourth inning
something to cheer about for the friar
faithful
at petco park tonight leave it to
fernando
manny machado is in third base with
trent grisham at second base
eric hosmer at first one out a run in
and will myers look out down goes myers
there's a slider and that is ball four
that'll bring in a run from third comes
machado
that's for himself they need length from
him yep
there's a pitcher it's a tough spot bad
timing right here's what it is yeah
camarena to deep right field camarena
plays it slam diego are you kidding me
the padres pitcher that he's brought up
from el paso
the san diego kid to the grand slam
that's unbelievable oh my gosh
well we know now the hot zone
off the battle daniel camarena
down and in that was unbelievable
john you mentioned his family is in
attendance oh my god
unbelievable we worked real hard for
a lot a lot many years little league
travel ball
we went at it we my mom and dad bought a
batting cage
and and that's all we did and so it's
just very very
rewarding and it feels very beautiful to
be living this moment
honoring mom dad our family all our
friends the community
doing it here in our hometown i i just
you can't script it you just can't
script it max scherzer with an eight
nothing lead
is going to leave this game in the
fourth inning tatis homer to begin this
inning
in the air shallow right back is belle
soto coming in it's gonna fall fam's
gonna score
it's a one-run game unraveling here
in the fourth way out in front gets
under it
i don't see any communication though
that's soto's ball he's got to take
charge
on that it's a base hit it's an rbi
fernando takes off for second base the
pitch is high the throw
not in time stolen base for fernando
tatis jr
he's a 20-20 man before the break that's
his 20th stolen base
20 before the break that's unbelievable
for fernando
that's great to left field
harrison going towards the corner will
make the catch
the inning is over but not before the
padres score seven
times big spot here for tommy fam in the
sixth inning
padres at one point in this game trailed
eight to nothing
in the air to center field robles going
back it's going to be over his head
what ups the wall from third comes myers
of this game
this game is tied padres trailed ain't
nothing
not anymore cronenworth has yet to join
the hit parade he is
flight out to center with a diving catch
by robla as he struck out and then lined
deep left
both turns kick some pitches and a line
drive center field chasing in his robles
dives again
and he robs him again the third time in
the series cronenworth has been robbed
by victor robles
and that'll give josh bell a chance
bell lines one caught at second base
he hit it to the ground zone you can hit
it anywhere
but don't hit it at the ground zone
winning run at third base
grisham lies it into right from third
country
padres trail made nothing they walk it
off
nine eight it's san diego sending the
friar faithful into a frenzy